[Music]
hello everyone so today i worked on the
quran from box french suite and e-flat
major
and i'd like to show you some clips from
my practice session
i first worked on it with a metronome
where instead of putting the tick on the
beat i put it at the end of the beat
specifically on the third eighth note of
each group of three
[Music]
three one
[Music]
one two three one two
[Music]
so i'm doing this because there's a
tendency to crunch
these groups of three eighth notes all
the time in
movements like this especially for
myself
i think stylistically there is a little
little little bit of scrunching of the
notes to get that currant dance-like
style
but it's very easy to end up rushing
instead
the second thing i want to make note of
is the trills
so this is actually immortant so you
play
the whole tone below
the actual note if it's a trill it's the
opposite
so since the pitches are f and g
i'm going to linger first on the f
and then finish the morning
right before the next beat
[Music]
the timing of this is hard to calculate
so what i'm doing to practice it is to
just practice it over and over up by
step
[Music]
the other type of chill or mordant that
i'm doing is here
[Music]
let me try that again
okay so basically i'm doing a morgan on
the g
[Music]
but since it's going at a relatively
fast tempo the notes blend together
so here's just a run through of the
quran
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so that's it for today i hope you found
that useful or interesting and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
no no no that
[Music]
and that does not include
so materials like